Honduras se suma a la lista de países
que por establecer relaciones con china
le han dado la espalda a Taiwán la
presidenta Xiomara Castro anunció que
Tegucigalpa retomar a las relaciones con
Beijing una noticia que celebró el
portavoz del Ministerio de relaciones
exteriores de china acogemos con
beneplácito de las declaraciones
pertinentes de la parte hondureña el
hecho de que 181 países en el mundo
hayan establecido relaciones
diplomáticas con china sobre la base del
principio de una sola china demuestra
plenamente que establecer relaciones
diplomáticas con china es la opción
correcta de acuerdo con la tendencia
general del desarrollo histórico y la
tendencia del Progreso de los tiempos
Pero cuál es el interés de China por los
países Centroamericanos A diferencia de
su predilección por México Brasil o
Venezuela ricos en materias primas china
ha puesto sus ojos en Centroamérica por
su privilegiada posición geográfica en
2007 inició relaciones diplomáticas con
Costa Rica país que le sirvió como
trampolín para estrechar lazos con otros
más de la región bajo una aparente
diplomacia de en los años posteriores
vino el apoyo de Beijing a la expansión
del canal de Panamá su posible
participación económica a un ferrocarril
interoceánico en Honduras o los planes
hasta ahora inciertos de un canal por
Nicaragua además china Busca la
concesión del puerto de La Unión
centroamericana en el extremo
suroriental de El Salvador en el Golfo
de Fonseca y en el que podría lograr un
puente entre el Atlántico y el Pacífico
para la construcción de refinerías y
oleoductos para Taiwán todo este
panorama es un error
la única motivación para que china
desarrolle lazos con Honduras es limitar
el espacio internacional de Taiwán no
tiene intención de implementar ninguna
asociación que pueda ser beneficiosa
para el pueblo de Honduras Honduras
debería reconsiderar seriamente y no
caer en la trampa china
el costo a pagar de la relación entre
China y Centroamérica es que los países
latinos deban cortar vínculos con Taiwán
que Beijing reclama como suya y que sólo
dejaría a la isla con 13 socios
internacional es